Ich fang mal mit was lustigem an.
Und zwar, ähm, der Verschwörungs...
Ja, 13. Ja, 13. Ja, guck mal.
Also, ich zähl da ja wirklich alles mit.
Ich zähl da auch sowas hier mit, was ich gar nicht mehr im Einsatz hab.
Sowas zähl ich ja auch mit.
Das ist das erste Tegra Nvidia Tablet gewesen.
Das kam raus 2013, ja.
Sowas zähl ich da auch mit.
Ja, der Ruby-Typ, Patrick, der war wenigstens doch lustig, ja.
Also, wir haben so einen Verschwörungstheorie-Man auf der Arbeit.
Der ist immer ein bisschen...
Der ist voll up-to-date, was solche Sachen angeht, ja.
Also, der weiß beispielsweise auch über Sonnenaktivität und Klimaerwärmung und...
Ach, alle möglichen Sachen.
Zumindest, ich bin da.
Der war da.
Ja, ich bin da am Freitagabend reingekommen.
Ich hab meine Maske auf.
Ich muss ja dann eine Maske aufziehen, sonst darfst du dich ja gar nicht mehr...
Also, wirklich bewegen, ohne dass sich irgendeiner anscheißt.
Nee, ich hab ja auch nicht alle Tablets gekauft dabei, ne.
Ich hätt mir doch nicht...
Leute, ich kauf mir doch keine 13 Tablets.
Das...
Ich bin...
Ich hab sie zwar nicht mehr alle, ja.
Aber ganz so bescheuert bin ich auch nicht, dass ich mir 13 Tablets kauf.
Ja, also...
Das hier hab ich damals von Nvidia gekriegt.
Das eine...
Das Shield-TV und das Ersatzschild...
Shield-TV hab ich auch von Nvidia gekriegt.
Und...
Ähm...
So ein Lenovo-Ding.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es heißt.
Das hab ich damals von G2A gekriegt.
Also, es sind schon mal 4 Tablets von den 13 Tablets nicht selbst gekauft.
Das ist jetzt die, die mir so spontan einfallen.
Davon sind dann auch noch 1, 2 Ultra-Low-Budget-Fire-HDs.
Ach, ich muss echt mal überlegen, im Kopf, wie ich das zusammenkrieg.
Dann mein Fire HD 7.
Das war auch nicht teuer.
War sich im Bett zum Streams gucken und YouTube gucken.
Was verwende...
Ähm...
Das iPad.
Das...
Doch, das Asus-Ding.
Das Asus ZenPad hab ich mir...
Hab ich gekauft.
Hab ich für meine Mutter zum Geburtstag gekauft.
Das weiß ich noch.
Weil ich...
Weil die war damals hauptsächlich Android gewöhnt.
Ich hab mir gedacht, da kaufst du dir auch ein Android-Tablet.
Ein ordentliches, weil die ist ja Android schon gewöhnt.
Und das war so kacke.
Das Asus ZenPad.
Und die haben auch schon irgendwie gefühlt am halben Jahr das Support eingestellt.
So.
Also...
Naja, so.
So, das ist eins davon.
So, also.
Genau, was war's?
Ich guck mal so mal im Chat gucken.
Ich glaub, ich hab bestimmt irgendwas übersehen.
Einer gesappt oder sonst was.
Wie gesagt, ich konnte gestern keinen Apple-Stream machen.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
So.
Genau, also.
Wir haben so eine Verschwörungstheorie, Mann.
Der ist immer auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Und ich bin am Freitag reingekommen.
In die Arbeit.
Ich hatte meine Maske auf.
Und da hab ich so gesagt,
Ah, Manfred, wie geht's?
Und...
Hab mich dann hingesetzt.
Und hab halt erzählt,
Hier, könnt ihr mal kurz für mich bitte das und das gucken und so.
Und dann meint er so von der Seite,
Hä?
Ich versteh dich nicht.
Da hab ich gesagt, hä?
Wie, warum?
Kommen die Schallwellen nicht bis zu dir oder was?
Ähm...
Kommen die Schallwellen nicht zu dir?
Ja, nee, nee, nee.
Ich hab Ohrentzündung.
Da hab ich dann die Maske ausgezogen.
Und dann meinte er dann auf einmal so,
Ah, ja, ja.
Jetzt versteh ich dich.
Also das ist im Prinzip so ein...
So...
Eine Masche von dem jetzt,
um die anderen Leute quasi...
In seiner Welt zu überzeugen,
dass Maske aufziehen dumm ist.
Sowas nach dem Motto.
So.
Und...
Einen Tag später kommt er an,
mit so einem riesen Windschild.
Ich weiß nicht...
Wie heißen diese Dinger?
Diese Maskenersatz...
Diese Maskenersatzdinger.
Diese...
Ähm...
Corona-Schild.
Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt.
Nee.
Wie heißen die Dinger denn?
Diese...
Diese Scheiben, die man sich...
Plexiglasschild.
Schild.
Nee.
Ähm...
Face...
Face-Shield.
Genau, genau.
Der kommt echt ohne Mist
mit so einem riesen Ding-Komm da an, äh.
Und...
Der hat es das ganze Tag nicht angehabt.
Der hat das immer nur an der Hose hängen.
Ries...
Dieses Riesenschild an der Hose hängen.
Und zieht das nie an,
dass wenn ihn einer fragt,
wie es mit Maske aussieht,
dass er dann sagen kann,
Alter, ich hab's...
Ich hab das...
Das Schild dabei.
Er ist...
Okay.
Der ist...
Ja, sorry.
Der ist ein bisschen...
Ist ein bisschen...
Bisschen merkwürdig irgendwie.
Ähm...
Lustigerweise, wo es dann um was ging,
wo er was wissen wollte,
dann hat er mich wieder verstanden.
Aber der ist wirklich...
Der...
Wie gesagt, der erzählt auch die ganze Zeit
von irgendwelchen Sonnenwinden
und Sonnenaktivität,
wenn da irgendwas vom Klima geschieht.
Also, ich bin ja jemand...
Ich sag's ja auch im Stream oft, ja.
Man sollte nicht alles grundsätzlich,
wenn es einem nicht gefällt,
als Verschwörungstheorie abtun.
Sondern sich ein bisschen mehr drüber reden.
Ähm...
Ja, mit dem kannst du aber nicht reden.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Der hat für mich einfach...
Der hat für mich einfach einen Knall,
was das anbelangt.
Ansonsten ist das ein...
Ansonsten kommt man super mit dem klar.
Ähm...
Der ist aber allgemein, glaube ich,
ein bisschen unausgeglichen, weil...
Der ist so...
Der hat nur zwei Betriebsmodi, der Kerl.
Also, der hat nur...
Ich hänge in den Seilen rum.
Nee, ich bin...
Ich bin nicht erkältet.
Ich hab wahrscheinlich die letzten Tage
ein bisschen viel geschwätzt, auch, ja.
Also, der hat nur zwei Betriebsmodi.
Der kann entweder in den Seilen hängen
und keinen Bock und YouTube gucken oder sowas.
Oder der ist voll auf 180.
Ähm...
Und der hat mal...
Der hat mal wirklich, ähm...
Der nicht kaputt gemacht, aber...
Dafür gesorgt, dass ich einen Fleck...
Einen dauerhaften Fleck auf dem Monitor hatte.
Weil der war so energisch beim...
Beim Deuten auf meinen TFT damals.
Da, da, da, da, da, da.
Also, du hast quasi gefühlt...
Das hat quasi so...
Den Eindruck gemacht, als sticht er mit seinem Zeigefinger
gleich durch den Bildschirm durch.
Und er ist dann immer...
Der ist entweder übelst hyperaktiv oder...
Oder halt...
Hängt er komplett in den Seilen, ey.
Naja, gut, was auch immer.
Gut, ähm...
Und das andere, was ich euch noch erzählen wollte, ist...
Äh, unser...
Unser neuer Azubi hat letztens...
Ich glaub, vorge...
Nee.
Ach, kann nicht so scheißegal, wann das gewesen ist.
Äh, was hast du für einen Dick, dass du immer...
Ich lösche nicht zwei Zeichen.
Ich lösche ein Zeichen.
Man muss da schon...
Korrekt sein, ja?
Also, ähm...
Unser Azubi...
Hat letztens...
Zu mir gesagt, ob ich am Sonntagmorgen auf Twitch gestreamt hab.
Hat er mich gefragt.
Und da hab ich gesagt, hä?
Ja, hab ich, hab ich.
Äh, sag mal...
Sag mal, Channel-Namen, wie es anfängt.
Da hat er gesagt, weh.
Er hat gesagt, weh.
Ja.
Da ist mir nur als Antwort eingefallen, dass Twitch halt wohl besser weiß, was er gucken will, als er selbst.
Und, ähm...
Und dann ist ihm...
Es geht ja noch weiter.
Es geht ja noch...
Es ist ja noch, noch, noch mehr Keck-Weight.
Es geht ja noch weiter.
Ähm...
Und danach hat er gesagt, er hat sich meinen Channel angeguckt und ihm ist aufgefallen, dass ich auch noch einen YouTube-Channel hab.
Und dann hat er gesagt, da war er voll mindblown, weil er immer mit 14, 15 meine YouTube-Videos geguckt hat, als er noch Call of Duty gespielt hat.
Ja.
Richtig, richtig Hardcore.
Ultraleague.
Ja.
So, jetzt wollte ich mal kurz hier gucken.
Also, Leute, ich glaube, wir haben nichts Großartiges vor, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, fragen wollt, sonst was.
Äh, ich hab immer ein Auge auf den Chat, wisst ihr ja.
Ähm, ich hab nur einfach gedacht, bevor ich die nächsten Tage das wieder überhaupt nicht...
Ich hab nur einfach gedacht, bevor ich die nächsten Tage das wieder überhaupt nicht...
Ich hab nur einfach gedacht, bevor ich die nächsten Tage das wieder überhaupt nicht hinbekomme, irgendwie, da, zu streamen, so.
Dann mach ich jetzt einfach mal kurz an.
Äh, RTX 3080, äh, 3090, ja, leider heute noch nicht, ne?
Am 29. war das doch.
Nvidia Shop.
Wir hatten doch schon geguckt, ich hab mir das doch schon...
vorgemerkt.
3080 Benchmarks, zeig mal her.
Was, 24, äh, was?
PS5-Event?
Wann ist PS5-Event?
In eins, oh, nee, das ist zu spät.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Ich muss morgen früh wieder auf...
Nee, nee, nee.
Das krieg ich nicht hin.
So, aber zeig mal her.
Äh, 3080 Benchmarks.
PC-Games-Hardware, die sind immer gut.
Welche Grafikkarte würde...
würdest du dir holen?
Nein, wenn ich mir jetzt was holen würde und...
Also, wenn ich jetzt mir einen neuen PC bauen könnte,
dann würde ich eine 3090 holen.
Aber ich kann jetzt ja keinen PC bauen,
weil mir die AMD-CPUs fehlen.
So, also bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Wo sind die Benchmarks?
Brauch Benchmarks.
Gefette Style ist es schon.
Aber das ist nicht höher als die alte.
Hier. Ne.
Technik Faunus. Spiele Benchmarks.
Da wird es doch interessant.
So. Also.
Spiele Benchmarks.
Zeig mal her.
Also. Wo?
Was ist das jetzt?
Ach. Anno. Warte mal.
Wollen wir was anderes machen?
Äh. Nicht Anno.
Battlefield. Okay.
Battlefield läuft ja auch immer ganz gut.
Ähm.
Oh.
Oh. Das ist schon eine ganze Ecke
schneller als eine 2080 Ti.
Was ist denn das?
20% oder so.
Hm. Ich kann jetzt nicht
schnell Quickmuffs im Kopf machen.
Was ist denn das?
Ja. 27%.
Das ist ordentlich.
Also. Im Vergleich zur
letzten Generation ist das wirklich viel.
Also. Jetzt müssen wir mal überlegen.
Also.
Wenn schon die
27. Okay. Das ist jetzt Battlefield.
Ja. Sag mal dahingestellt.
Also. Aber wenn schon die 3080
sagen wir mal
sind wir mal großzügig.
Ich sag mal 25%.
Runden wir mal ein bisschen ab.
Wenn die schon 25% schneller ist
als eine 2080 Ti
dann ist ja die 3090
bestimmt, sagen wir mal, mindestens 35%
schneller. Oder 30.
30. 30 bis 35.
Sagen wir mal 35. Sagen wir mal 35.
Das ist schon sehr ordentlich.
Muss man sagen.
Das ist schon echt nicht schlecht.
Also zumindest mehr als die letzten Generationen.
Ja gut. Black Mesa läuft ja nun wirklich überall drauf.
Wie ist denn so der Vergleich zu meiner?
Haben die eine 1080 Ti drinne hier?
Guckt mal der Unterschied von der 2080 Ti zur 1080 Ti.
Ja doch. Das ist auch.
Ist auch.
Ist ungefähr genauso viel.
Da kannst du es eigentlich.
So. Was haben wir noch? Black Mesa.
Juckt mich jetzt auch nicht. Borderlands 3.
Okay. Ja ist aber trotzdem ganz ordentlich.
Also ich werde mir.
Wir waren doch letztens auf so einer Pre-Order Seite für eine 3.
Ach hier.
Wobei mal ganz ehrlich.
Es ist unglaublich teuer.
Das ist eigentlich total unsinnig.
Teuer.
Aber ich glaube.
Wenn es AMD schafft.
Einen ordentlichen.
Eine ordentliche CPU rauszubringen.
Dass ich auch CPU mäßig ein bisschen ein Upgrade habe.
Dann kaufe ich mir eine.
Und baue mir einen neuen Rechner Ende des Jahres.
Wobei die Dinger eh nicht lieferbar sind.
Der Chat ist da.
Vor was?
Hier.
1499.
Aber dazu muss es AMD schaffen.
Ich warte mal auf die Benchmarks.
13090.
Hä?
Warum kostet die.
Achso derzeit nicht verfügbar.
Also ich meine.
Die Karte hier ist.
Die Karte ist quasi.
25% schneller.
Ja was auch immer.
Scheiße für alle Leute die sich echt.
Im letzten halben Jahr so ein Ding gekauft haben.
Ansonsten bin ich der Meinung.
Muss sich da keiner großartig beschweren.
Wenn die erste Generation raus kommt.
Ist die ältere Generation meistens am Arsch.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Die letzte Generation war das nicht mehr so.
Aber ich bin es einfach noch gewöhnt.
Äh.
Ja und?
Was ist das Problem?
Aber ob das Money Waste wird.
Muss ich erst mal zeigen.
Das muss ich erst mal zeigen.
Also wenn das Ding nochmal 15% schneller ist.
Warum nicht?
Das ist normal.
Weil man für die letzten 15% im Verhältnis.
Unglaublich viel mehr bezahlt.
Als für die 15% davor.
Hast du einen 4K Monitor?
Nein habe ich nicht.
Aber ich brauche mehr FPS.
Bisschen Flex ist natürlich auch dabei.
Und was bei mir hauptsächlich ist.
Weil ich meine.
Bei wem soll ich großartig flexen.
Außer vom Stream.
Was bei mir hauptsächlich der Fall ist.
Warum ich eine 3090 will.
Wenn es denn eine neue AMD CPU gibt.
Weil ich meine.
Ich habe es jetzt so oft gesagt.
Es kann doch nicht sein.
Dass ein Rechner.
Von vor ziemlich genau 3 Jahren.
Immer noch zu den besten Systemen gehört.
Mit einer 1080Ti und 8700K.
Das kann nicht sein nach 3 Jahren.
Das passt einfach nicht.
In mein Hirn rein.
Ich bin ja jemand.
Der ist aus einer Zeit.
Da war nach 2 Jahren dein Rechner Schrott.
Und so richtig Schrott.
Ich habe noch Athlon XP gekauft.
Und solche Dinger.
Ja.
Wisst ihr was meine erste Grafikkarte war.
Die ich gekauft habe.
Also zusätzlich.
Die nicht im Rechner drin war.
Die erste Grafikkarte die ich zusätzlich gekauft habe.
Das war damals eine.
Elsa Eraser 2.
Da kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern.
Ne keine Voodoo.
Ne eine TNT1 war das.
Eine TNT1 Karte.
Moment die gibt es noch zu kaufen.
Warum gibt es die noch zu kaufen.
Ah ne passt.
Gibt es die noch zu kaufen.
Okay used.
Huge.
8,95 Euro.
Ja das war die erste Grafikkarte.
Nein nein nein nicht die.
Die da war das.
Das ist Fake.
Die sah nicht so aus.
So sah die aus.
Das weiß ich noch ganz genau.
AGP Slot Leute.
Und das war der RAM.
Das war in der GameStar.
Das war noch eine Zeit wo ich quasi jede GameStar gekauft habe.
In der GameStar habe ich damals gelesen.
Das das eine unglaubliche.
Transistordichte ist.
Von 2 Millionen Transistoren.
Auf ungefähr einer Größe von einem Centstück.
Oder Pfennigstück oder so.
Das ist halt der Witz.
2 Millionen.
Heute sind es keine Ahnung 7 Milliarden oder so.
Da kräht heute kein Hahn mehr danach.
2 Millionen.
Das juckt heute absolut keinen.
2 Millionen hat irgendein billig AliExpress China Prozessor.
Den sie in irgendeinem.
In dem dunklen China Keller.
Zusammen gezimmert haben.
Wobei die Chinesen sind clever.
Was das angeht.
Die machen das ja so.
Bei AliExpress.
Die haben jetzt ja Notebook.
Die nehmen ja Notebook CPUs.
Und setzen die auf einen Sockel.
Das die in Desktop Mainboards reinpassen.
Moin.
Leku.
Die können die Notebook CPUs mit Desktop Sockel kaufen.
Die modden.
Die modden alte Notebook CPUs.
Excellent.
Die Sockel Notebook CPUs.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Weil ihr wisst ja.
Der Kram bei AliExpress ist immer unglaublich billig.
Und.
Die Notebook CPUs sind gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ja warum nicht.
Also wenn ihr irgendwelche Low End Sachen kaufen willst.
Warum nicht.
So ich wollte jetzt nochmal schnell nach dem iPad 8 gucken.
Was da so Sache ist.
Übrigens mein FFZ ist irgendwie kaputt.
Auch nicht warum.
Ich kann mein Chat immer noch nicht richtig scrollen.
Also wenn das stimmt.
Wo hast du überall damals pre-ordert.
Was meinst du für die CPU.
Auch bei irgendwie 60 verschiedenen Shops.
Moin Herz93.
Also wenn das stimmt.
Das die neuen AMD CPUs auch 30% schneller werden.
Dann ist.
Neuer Rechner Ende des Jahres ist raus.
Vorausgesetzt man kriegt die Hardware.
So also ich wollte mal kurz gucken.
Wie ist denn das diesmal wieder bei Apple.
Kann man die Dinger gleich kaufen.
Kann man die direkt kaufen wieder.
Das macht ja Apple ganz gerne.
Dass die was ankündigen.
Und dann kannst du sofort ordern.
Ach ab Oktober ok.
Ok also iPad 8 was ist da drinne.
Notebook ist mir eigentlich egal.
Wo wir uns das angucken.
Ich will nur mal kurz schauen was da drinne ist.
Also.
Quatsch.
Klar.
Irgendwas ordentlich.
Ja gut hier.
Was gab es denn bei Apple.
Ich habe nicht geguckt.
Ich habe nur heute morgen gesehen das es ein neues iPad gibt.
Da wollte ich jetzt mal gucken was das kostet.
Und was da drin ist.
Also erstmal wird das iPad 7 durch das iPad 8 ersetzt.
Ok.
Das ist die CPU vom.
Vom letzten iPad.
Air oder so.
Ich glaube irgendwie sowas.
Blick bei der CPU Bezeichnung von.
Apple nicht mehr so ganz durch.
So.
Er soll laut Apple 40%.
Es ist ja schön und gut.
Dass das alles immer schneller wird.
Ich finde das auch nicht verkehrt.
Wobei man halt echt sagen muss.
Dass die iPads so gut flutschen.
Weiß nicht ob ich die 40% wirklich merke.
Apple Watch SE.
Ja Apple Watch ist so ein Ding.
Das geht mir eigentlich ziemlich am Arsch vorbei.
Doch doch ich habe gelesen.
Die Apple Watch.
Die kann jetzt irgendwie Blut.
Sauerstoff?
Irgendwas genau.
Aber das juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Blutsauerstoff.
Sauerstoff galt irgendwie sowas.
Ist Wupplos ein Apple User?
Naja also ich habe hier ein iPad.
Und ich habe zwei iPhones.
Der Rest ist alles Android.
So also.
iPad ist ab Freitag verfügbar.
Also.
Übermorgen.
Hätte mal Microsoft.
Arbeit reingesteckt.
Wie hier in diesem Kalender.
Dass das hier durchschimmert.
Wobei das ist ziemlich simpel zu machen.
Eigentlich ist das ziemlich simpel zu machen.
Okay ich sag nicht was ich sagen wollte.
Also eigentlich wollte ich.
Dachte ich aber das ist keine Arbeit.
Das ist total easy zu machen sowas.
Also.
Was ich eigentlich wollte.
Die hätten mal in andere Teile von Windows.
So viel Arbeit reinstecken sollen.
Weil guckt mal hier.
Wenn ich mal ein Task. Ich hoffe der ist jetzt fertig.
Wenn ich mal ein Task Manager gucke.
Seit ich geupdatet habe.
Ist also.
Seit.
Vorgestern oder so.
Ist der Windows Search Indexer am indexen.
Gut der indiziert auch.
Meine SSD und er indiziert auch meine.
Aber was macht der denn da?
Oder ist das ein Virus?
Was indiziert der da?
Naja.
Ich habe auf 2004 geupdatet.
BND, LSA.
Der Bundes.
Der Bundes Search Indexer.
Der Kommentator.
9 Monate.
Excellent.
Subscription.
Also was ist ab Freitag verfügbar?
Kostet.
369,40.
Also entweder sind das.
Von Dollar umgerechnete Preise.
Oder aber.
Es ist der alte Trick.
Man macht einen Kommabetrag.
Das es so klingt wie so nach dem Motto.
Es ist reguliert billiger.
Kriegen wir es nicht hin.
Das bist du.
Chat.
Seid ihr eingeloggt?
Beim Search Indexer.
I'm in.
Mit SIM Karte.
Brauche ich nicht.
SIM Karte ist overrated im iPad.
Braucht man gar nicht.
Ähnlich ist es in den Farben.
Silber.
Space Grey.
Gold.
Aha.
Besonders iPad 4 Air.
Das ist mir zu teuer.
Was kostet das?
Was?
Die haben 120 Hertz auf dem Tablet jetzt?
Die haben auf dem Tablet.
Mehr Bildwiederholrate.
Als aktuelle Konsolen.
Muss man sich auch mal vorstellen.
Bei der PS5 sieht es dann wieder.
Ein bisschen anders aus.
Aber ich wette mit euch.
Die.
Erzählen ja auch.
Jetzt schon.
Die werden ja auch nicht müde zu betonen.
Wie geil jetzt Xbox.
Die neue Xbox ist.
Ich sag es euch.
Es wird auf gar keinen Fall.
So sein.
Dass die meisten Spiele.
Auch nur ansatzweise 120 FPS.
120 Hertz ist ja das eine.
120 FPS laufen werden auf der PS5.
Im Leben nicht.
Also wie viel kostet der Kram jetzt?
Zu teuer.
Das Magic Keyboard für.
Was?
Warum ist das.
Warum kostet das Keyboard die Hälfte vom.
WTF?
Warum.
Warum kostet eine Tastatur.
Die Hälfte vom Gerät.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Okay.
Das erscheint mir ein bisschen viel irgendwie.
Gut.
Man darf nicht vergessen.
Wie war das.
Und die Wiese Halterung 200.
Bei Apple ist das alles kein Problem.
Hat es wenigstens.
RGB Beleuchtung auf der Tastatur.
Ich hoffe.
Ich kann jetzt wieder hoch scrollen.
Irgendwie buggt mein FFZ.
Übelst rum gerade.
Chat aufgrund von Scroll angehalten.
WTF.
Warum ist mein FFZ so im Arsch.
Chat aufgrund von Scroll angehalten.
Was auch immer.
Ist auch egal.
Titan Toaster.
Ach doch.
Hat das Abo verlängert.
Von Sebaro11.
Der Name ist gerade Zeilen umgebrochen.
Excellent.
Dankeschön.
Okay.
Das ist mir alles zu teuer.
Ein iPad 8.
Habe ich keinen Bedarf für.
Ich habe schon ein iPad 6.
Das reicht noch voll und ganz.
Aber ich wollte einfach mal gucken.
Was die so Neues am Start haben.
Übrigens.
Avira geht mir mega auf den Sack.
Also ich habe ja schon ewig.
Den Kram nicht mehr installiert.
Aber auf meinem Streaming Rechner.
Ich tausche den Kram ja immer durch.
Also wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe.
Dann wird der alte Rechner zum Streaming Rechner.
Und auf dem ist schon seit Ewigkeiten Avira installiert.
Und ich habe es nie runter geschmissen.
Und das nötigt mich jetzt hier übelst.
Mit irgendwie.
Dass ich irgendwelche Privacy Sachen updaten soll.
Und sowas.
Ich will kein Prime.
Ich will einfach das es mir nicht auf den Sack geht.
Ich soll mich einfach in Ruhe lassen.
Gut.
Ich könnte es auch deaktivieren.
Aber das geht natürlich auch.
Ich muss gerade noch mal in meine FFZ Settings.
Weil das gerade wirklich.
Echt nervig.
Scroll.
Okay das geht gerade nicht.
Ist gerade kaputt.
Übelst der Müll der Kram.
Reicht der Defender?
Klar.
Ganz ehrlich.
Windows Defender ist das Beste was du machen kannst.
Der Rest ist komplett sinnlos.
Was ist eigentlich gerade so in den Github Trends?
Mal gucken was es da so interessantes Neues gibt.
Ja.
Windows Defender ist wirklich das Beste.
Also ich habe seit.
Drei Jahren jetzt.
Keinen.
Kein Antivirus Gedulds mehr.
Wozu auch.
Davor auf dem Rechner.
Hattest du halt noch Avira drauf.
Hast du halt so blöden Absichten installiert.
Linux braucht keinen Avira.
Ja das ist richtig.
Unter Linux brauchst du viele Sachen nicht.
Unter Windows brauchst du.
Umgedreht hast du halt unter Linux das Problem.
Das manche Sachen schlicht und ergreifend nicht gibt.
Also die Beste.
Die Beste Kombi ist tatsächlich NoScript.
Beziehungsweise sowas wie AdBlock.
Oder halt hier UBlock.
Und weil es auch gerade jemand im Chat schreibt.
Und der Windows Defender.
Sonst braucht man nichts.
Hast du den Active Directory.
Exploit die Tage gesehen.
Welchen da gibt es immer so viele.
Den da.
Doch Netlogon.
Das ist AD.
12 Monate.
Was benutzt du für einen Kalender.
Immer noch den aus Nextcloud.
Weil der sich halt gut synken lässt.
Aber wie gesagt.
Ich will ja schon seit Monaten Nextcloud loswerden.
Übrigens.
Ich habe was was wir demnächst im Stream machen müssen.
Weil ich will mein Setup umstellen.
Da habe ich ja hier.
Ähm.
Dogger.
Mit Traffic als Reverse Proxy.
Für Let's Encrypt am Start.
Das müssen wir mal was anderes machen.
Ich will das mal mit Caddy ausprobieren.
Das müssen wir uns in einem der nächsten Streams mal angucken.
Weil da habe ich.
Irgendwas gefunden heute.
Auf Github.
Was quasi ähnlich funktioniert wie Traffic.
Und die Traffic Config ist halt eklig.
Die Caddy Config ist viel einfacher.
Da wollte ich mal gucken.
Ob man da was gutes draus basteln kann.
Da geht das Stream nur in dem Video.
Das kann sein.
Die Caddy Config ist wirklich simpel.
Kannst du im Stream mal was mit Python machen.
Oder wie ich früher immer gesagt habe.
Wo ich auch keine Ahnung habe.
Python.
Ich habe letztens.
Also Offstream.
Muss ich sagen.
Was in Python gemacht.
Und das war wirklich sehr angenehm.
Und zwar.
Ich sollte die Config von einem Windows DHCP.
Konvertieren.
Also Export.
CSV Export von einem Windows DHCP.
Also ich meine allein schon CSV Export.
Da bist du schon.
Da hast du schon keinen Bock mehr eigentlich.
Warum kann der Windows DHCP.
Überhaupt exportieren als CSV.
Zumindest.
CSV exportiert.
Also richtig Monarch S.
Und Kobold Stream an Weihnachten.
Und dann sollte ich das ganze importieren.
DHCP ISC ICS DHCP ISC.
Ich kann mir aber nicht merken wie rum das Ding heißt.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht.
Komm machst du mal ein kleines Python.
Skript.
Und ich muss sagen.
Das war wirklich sehr erholsam.
Also.
Die Python Standard Library ist gut.
Du hast einen IP Calculator dabei.
Das DHCP Ranges ausrechnen kann.
Und solche Geschichten.
Du hast alles mögliche dabei gehabt.
Das war wirklich angenehm.
Deswegen.
Wir können durchaus mal in einem der nächsten Streams was machen.
Allerdings bin ich ja nur echt nicht der großartige Pro.
Hast du irgendeine Idee?
Ich kann leider nicht gescheit hochscrollen im Chat.
Außer hier über.
Komische.
Ich habe doch immer das geschrieben.
Hast du irgendeine Idee was wir machen können?
Kupa 1338.
Wobei ich kann doch einfach hier im Chat scrollen.
Das geht doch.
Also hier.
Ich hatte letztens eine sehr lustige Situation.
Wo mir mal aufgefallen ist. Wie scheiße.
Was sind denn die Vorteile?
Braucht Ionenbau?
Kein Anfallangebot.
Wieso ist der abgeraucht?
Oder was?
Übrigens.
Wo wir beim Thema billig sind.
Ich habe mir vor einer Weile.
Die gibt es auch bei Amazon.
Deswegen zeige ich das jetzt mal da.
20er Park USB Sticks.
Bestellt.
Sowas hier.
4G oder so.
Hatte ich hier bestellt.
So.
Und ich sage gleich.
Kauft es euch nicht.
Nicht kaufen.
Ich zeige es jetzt nur weil ich sagen will wie schlecht die sind.
So.
Also da kriegst du ungefähr.
Für so.
Keine Ahnung.
2 Euro, unter 2 Euro den USB Stick.
Und die sehen halt auch schon so billig aus.
Und es war so.
Das wir auf der Arbeit.
Viele Linux Sachen oldschool installieren mussten.
Wie gesagt.
Bei uns ist ja ein paar Sachen kaputt gegangen.
Und wir mussten ganz klassisch Sachen installieren.
Per USB Stick.
Und ich habe so welche.
China eingekauft.
Schon vor einer ganzen Weile.
Also ich habe mehrere Packs gekauft.
Ich habe so billige gekauft.
Und ich habe auch 32 Gigabyte.
Bei AliExpress gekauft.
Und ich habe dann gesagt wisst ihr was Leute.
Ich bringe einfach.
15 oder 20er Pack.
USB Sticks mit.
Und jeder der was installieren muss.
Kann sich einen USB Stick schnappen.
Und vorher formatieren.
Und dann loslegen.
Und die Dinger sind so dermaßen schlecht.
Achso.
Ja das stelle ich der Firma in Rechnung.
Klar.
Ich bezahle doch keine 60 Euro nur das sie da ihr Zeug fixen können.
So.
Schauen wir das PS5 Event zusammen.
Ne da muss ich leider pennen.
Das kriege ich nicht gebacken.
PS5 Event.
Vielleicht schaffen wir es doch noch.
Startet in Kürze.
Okay wann geht das los.
Livestream auf Youtube.
Noch gar nicht.
10pm.
Kann man das auch mal auf Deutsch machen.
Ich finde den Youtube Jugendschutz geil.
Habt ihr das wieder gesehen.
22 Uhr.
Mal gucken.
Der Youtube Jugendschutz ist geil oder.
Oh nein.
In 60 Minuten.
Okay.
Eigentlich dauert es zu lange.
Aber vielleicht.
Ne ich glaube nicht das ich das streamen kann.
Außer ich überlege es mir noch spontan anders.
Ja.
Zumindest diese USB Sticks übelst der Rotz.
Kauft es euch auf gar keinen Fall.
3 MB.
2 bis 3 MB die Sekunde.
Und jetzt kopiert mal.
Irgendwie sagen wir ein Ubuntu ISO mit 2,5G.
Mit 3 MB die Sekunde auf USB Sticks.
Genau.
Ach stimmt wir haben dafür sogar ein extra Sound.
Richtig eklig.
So aber trotzdem lustigerweise.
Ich habe da den 15er Pack USB Sticks hingelegt.
Und ich habe außer einem.
Der ist jetzt übrigens kaputt.
Keinen wieder bekommen.
Also ich werde jetzt hier der Firma.
Da trotzdem mal 50 Euro.
Für USB Sticks in Rechnung stellen.
Schon die ersten Tests gesehen.
Ja haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Ich persönlich finde es ganz ordentlich.
Ich bin 30, 90 gespannt.
Die Dinger sehen nach USB Werbesticks aus.
Ja sind sie im Prinzip auch.
Elektroschrott der Firma verkauft.
Es hat was gebracht.
Wir haben ein paar Kisten damit installiert.
Ich darf in der Berufsschule jetzt C lernen.
Da habe ich nicht so viel Lust drauf.
Naja also.
Da muss ich 2 Sachen zu sagen.
Erstens finde ich es doof mit C anzufangen.
Aber.
Du kannst froh sein das es kein C++ ist.
C++ ist wirklich.
Absolut.
Ich bin ein C++ Chef.
Sei froh das es nur C ist.
Ja also.
Wie gesagt.
Ich fange jetzt nicht davon an.
Weil ihr wisst genau.
Wenn ich von C++ anfange.
Dann ähm.
Arte das wieder darin aus.
Das ich mich eine halbe Stunde über C++ aufrege.
Warum C++ so schlecht ist.
Deswegen machen wir das nicht.
So.
Kann mal schnell was gucken.
Wenn ich C++ abfacke.
Weil C++ sackt.
Weil C++ das total.
Unnötig komplizierte.
Inkonsistenteste.
Crap an sich ist.
So aber mehr sage ich nicht.
Weil sonst hört es nicht mehr auf.
Ja.
Ich habe letztens.
Jetzt fange ich doch wieder an.
Ich habe letztens den Webcast geguckt.
Was du guckst dir jetzt.
C++ Roast PDF an.
Was?
Ne also.
Ich habe letztens den Webcast geguckt.
Ähm.
Und von irgendeiner C++ Konferenz.
Und ich war.
Absolut.
Absolut schockiert mal wieder.
Das die es nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Das Ding irgendwie halbwegs.
Halbwegs modern und unangenehm benutzbar zu machen.
Die haben da Dinger.
Teilweise vorgestellt.
Was andere Sprachen seit 10 Jahren oder 15 Jahren teilweise drin haben.
Sie haben sich abgefeiert.
Das die jetzt ordentliches.
String Formatting haben.
Ich meine es ist ja gut.
Das man das jetzt hat.
Aber es ist 2020.
Also ganz ehrlich.
2020 sollte sich keiner mehr mit.
Printf rumschlagen müssen.
In der Sprache die halt selbst irgendwie.
Ja es ist.
Schwierig zu sagen was C++ eigentlich sein will.
Auf der einen Seite wollen sie nicht High Level sein.
Aber auf der anderen Seite doch.
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Was auch immer.
Ich fange nicht an.
Sonst hört es nicht auf.
Der Sibaro sagt.
Was will demnächst mal alles Streams durchgehen.
Wo du auf Amazon Technik Kaufempfehlung gemacht hast.
Ne ne musst du nicht machen.
Das ist doch glaube ich.
Dann stelle ich dir eine Liste zusammen mit Reflinks.
Falls dir noch was einfällt.
Was noch fehlen kannst du.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Aber du musst da nicht großartig Streams durchgehen.
Das reicht ja auch wenn wir das ab jetzt machen.
So was trendet.
Warum trendet Ruby on Red.
Moment.
Trending mit 12 Stars.
Das ist ein bisschen wenig.
Hä.
Ähh. Github.
Was ist mit euch los.
Irgendwie falsch rum.
Und Developers können auch trenden.
Ich wusste gar nicht.
Dass Developers trenden können.
Ja.
Cute Developers.
So ähm.
Also warum Rails mit 12 Sternen trendet.
Ist mir nicht ganz klar.
Vor allem Ruby on Rails.
Ist ja nun wirklich.
2020 beim besten Willen.
Nicht mehr so großartig angesagt.
Also was trendet denn.
Mal kurz drüber gucken ob da irgendwas spannend ist.
Komm wir machen mal die Woche.
Wir machen heute und die Woche.
Also das hatten wir schon mal Rails.
Da ist es wieder.
Das kommt immer so unvorbereitet.
Springt es einen an.
Von der Seite.
MonkaS.
HashiCorp.
Ja die sind ganz dicke.
Was Cloud, Kubernetes, Service und so.
Und so Gedöns angeht.
Da hat man ganz viel von HashiCorp.
Das hört sich irgendwie fast illegal an.
Finde ich so der Name von denen.
Aber HashiCorp.
Die haben dann auch Konsul.
Was haben die noch?
Konsul?
Echt keine Ahnung.
Waren die das auch mit ETCD?
Terraform war das. Nicht Konsul.
Oder?
Vagrant ist auch von denen.
Terraform.
Terraform und Konsul.
Das sind eigentlich so die großen Dinger die man kennt.
Vault. Keine Ahnung.
Haben wir wahrscheinlich auch.
So es gibt eine neue Programmiersprache die sich Zik nennt.
Aha. Zik.
Oder Ziege.
Ziege.
Ähm.
Ich habe genug Programmiersprachen jetzt erst mal gelernt.
Das reicht mir.
Ich brauche.
Wie sieht denn die aus?
Ich brauche gerade nicht mehr.
Beispiel.
Ich brauche ein billiges.
Hello World will ich mir angucken.
Test.
Hello World.
Ja so.
Also wie sieht es aus?
Ich will einfach nur wissen wie es ausschaut.
Kann ja zu schwierig sein.
Hier. Da.
Aha.
Also eine Mischung aus.
Rust.
C.
Ruby.
JavaScript.
Na Go.
Ja vielleicht.
Nee nee nee.
Von Go hat es eigentlich nichts zu finden.
Go weiß ja auch nicht wie man Variablen anlegen soll.
Auch so ein Ding wo ich mich frage was sie sich bei Go gedacht haben.
So.
Also was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Schönes TypeScript Repo.
Gut das ist jetzt nicht so interessant.
Irgendwelche Sicherheitsgeschichten.
In Team Fortress 2.
Fork oder was ist das?
Den Fork können sie ja nicht machen.
Community Patches für Team Fortress 2.
Das ist ja nice.
Habt ihr übrigens gesehen das Left 4 Dead.
For Dead 2.
Bekommt jetzt ein neues Addon.
Ein Community Addon.
Nach sieben Jahren.
Die bekommen nach sieben Jahren.
Bekommen die jetzt ein.
Neues Update.
Ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Also Valve ist da genau das Gegenteil von Nintendo.
Hab ich den Eindruck.
Nintendo sagt.
Oh wie ihr habt ein Game gemacht.
Was mit unseren Marken irgendwas zu tun hat.
Instant Ban.
Anzeige, Klage alles raus.
Und Valve sagt.
Ha das Zeug ist ja gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja dann lass uns das doch mal bringen.
Das ist aber auch nicht einfach weil sie so nett sind.
Sondern letztendlich.
Aus ihren eigenen Gründen.
Was auch immer.
Rein die Kohle wird es in dem Fall nicht unbedingt sein.
Aber die haben bestimmt nicht nur reine Nächstenliebe da im Sinn.
Aber Nintendo ist da schon richtig übertrieben.
So.
TMP Meldung.
Irgendwie ist da diesmal nichts spannendes dabei.
Elasticsearch trendet.
Ist jetzt auch nichts neues.
Moment.
Nee ist irgendwie nichts spannendes dabei.
Äh Range Woche.
Ist das Update schon raus?
Äh nee.
Oh.
Ähm das Update ist noch nicht raus.
Die haben ja schon wieder dieses.
Könnt ihr euch ja dran erinnern.
Im letzten PS5 Stream.
Wo sie das Logo für jede Zwischenüberblendung immer anders gemacht haben.
Also das kommt.
Das kommt ja imnächst raus das Left 4 Dead Update.
Muss mal gucken.
Also wie gesagt.
Das dauert nicht mehr lang bis das rauskommt.
Irgendwann.
Am 30. September.
Also es ist bald.
Es dauert nicht mehr lang.
Eine Woche noch.
Excellent.
So.
Also was trendet denn hier?
Weiß ich nicht was das ist.
China Kram.
Pan Download.
Was ist das?
GitHub ist so voll mit China Kram mittlerweile.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht was das ist.
Was ist das?
Pan Download Server.
Was?
Kurukurumi.
Alles klar.
Google Translator.
Google Translate.
Ah.
Website übersetzen.
Geht das nicht mehr?
Kann man nicht mehr die Website übersetzen?
Man konnte doch mal Webseiten übersetzen lassen.
Ach nee das ist jetzt eingebaut.
Das ist jetzt eingebaut.
Ich weiß nicht wie man das bedient.
Wie?
Wie translatet man hier?
Ah.
Englisch.
Warum ist das so schlecht?
Warum kann ich hier nicht sagen.
Die versuchen wieder zu schlau zu sein bei Google.
Die versuchen wieder zu schlau zu sein.
So.
Ah.
Page is in.
Was heißt das?
Mandarin.
Warum kann ich keine Autodetection machen?
Wie heißt denn das?
Hier.
Chinese Translate.
Nicht German.
Nein.
Ich will nach Englisch.
Chinesisch nach Englisch.
Google please.
Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Google.
So.
Englisch.
Also.
Personal Maintenance Version of Pan Download.
Chinese Name Gabel Bug.
Ich habe absolut keinen
Plassen Schimmer was das ist.
Paratrooper Chat.
What?
Okay.
Was auch immer es ist.
Es ist Chinaspezifischer Kram der uns nicht interessieren muss.
So. Was haben wir sonst noch?
Ja genau.
Harmony OS ist das QoY OS.
Ja.
Okay.
Diagrams.
Connected Home IP.
C++.
Das kann Windows sein und macht das in irgendwelchen ordentlichen Sprachen.
Was?
Virtual Machines for iOS?
Was ist das?
It allows you to run Windows?
Android?
And more on your iPhone.
Get totem up.
Das kann ich bestimmt auf meinem iPhone nicht installieren.
Das gibt es bestimmt nicht im Store.
Ah. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
UTM does not require jailbreak.
Side loaded. Ja.
Das ist eine total beknackte Sache von Apple.
Mit diesem Side Load Restriction.
Also ich kann.
Das ist auch so eine Sache wo mir Apple auf den Keks geht.
Man kann doch nicht mal eine eigene Anwendung programmieren
und die auf sein iPhone
sideloaden und dann einfach verwenden.
Das geht nach 7 Tagen wieder weg.
Das ist so eine typische Apple Sache die mir auf den Sack geht.
All Store.
Ich bin geneigt
das mal auf einem iPad
auszuprobieren.
Oh.
iOS 17 UTM requires jailbreak to use.
Ne. Ne. Ne.
Dann sollte ich das vielleicht ausprobieren
bevor ich iOS 14 upgrade auf dem iPad.
Du kannst sie doch nicht mal kompilieren
und merk du brauchst Xcode.
Aber ich glaube du brauchst Xcode.
Also du kannst ohne Xcode
keine Apps veröffentlichen.
Du brauchst Xcode.
Es gibt für ganz wenige
Javascript Dinger.
Ich glaube für React Native
gibt es so Online Services
die für dich den Kram machen.
Aber dann bist du halt drauf beschränkt
für diese paar Online Services.
Die werden unter der Haube aber natürlich auch
eine Mac4M mit Xcode verwenden.
Das ist geil. Das gefällt mir.
Es ergibt zwar wenig Sinn.
Also man braucht
das nicht. Zumal man das auf dem
iPad schon mal gar nicht richtig bedienen kann.
Aber das ist trotzdem geil.
Man braucht es nicht aber es hat was.
Jetzt muss ich mal booken.
Das habe ich schon gemacht.
Der China Player.
Irgendwelche Karaoke Geschichten oder so.
Ach ne.
Lipsync Speech
Dings.
Sushi.
Sushi Swap.
Was trendet da alles auf GitHub?
Ich habe von dem ganzen Zeug ja nie was gehört.
Okay.
Es kriegt einfach viele Sterne
und man weiß nicht warum.
Alles klar.
I.
Das muss doch jetzt nicht wirklich sein oder?
Als erstes kommt C++
und jetzt trendet auch noch Java.
Sorry.
Aber so sind sie halt.
Ja und Nvidia hat ARM gekauft.
Stimmt.
Richtig.
Das war ja auch noch die letzten Tage angesagt.
Stimmt.
Nvidia hat ARM gekauft.
Oh ne. Wieder so nervige
Musik. Geh weg.
Ja. Aber das gerade Oracle
TikTok kaufen, finde ich immer noch merkwürdig.
Warum nicht einfach KVM
benutzen? Naja, wenn man Oracle Lizenzen
sparen kann, benutzt man halt Oracle
Visualisierungszeug. Bleibt ja mal nicht viel
anderes übrig.
PeepoFat.
Aber sowas von PeepoFat.
Excellent.
Huge PeepoFat.
Ja wahrscheinlich.
Das kling ich jetzt
nett an.
Das kling ich jetzt nett an.
Mein neuer Internetanbieter wirbt mit Glasfaseranschluss.
Aber es gibt nur 150
20 Mbit maximal.
Naja.
Kann auch Glasfaser sein.
Aber halt scheiß Geschwindigkeit.
Können wir uns den Clip von Linus
ansehen, wo er Fuck you Nvidia sagt?
Ne.
Jetzt nicht.
Das gucken wir uns mal sonntags an.
Also ich muss echt meinen Browser Vorschau fixen.
Das ist total nervig, dass ich auf dem zweiten Rechner
keinen, nicht hochscrollen
kann.
Alte Hardware. Du kennst wohl die Autoindustrie nicht.
Wieso ist da alte Hardware?
Überbieten die sich damit noch ältere Hardware?
Ne. Ich kenne die Autoindustrie wirklich nicht.
Das ist richtig.
Habt ihr gelesen
für wieviel Nvidia
Arm gekauft hat? Das waren ja irgendwie
keine Ahnung. 40 Milliarden
oder so. Das war übertrieben viel Geld.
Ja.
40 Milliarden.
Alter. Das ist mal was.
Microsoft hat damals
Minecraft Leute nur für eine
eine Milliarde gekauft.
Oder? War es überhaupt
ne Milli...
Was hat die
2,5 Milliarden?
Ah ne. 2,5 Milliarden.
War es damals. Ok.
Ok.
Ist jemand von euch so in dieser Minecraft
Geschichte drin?
Mögen die Leute Microsoft?
Mögen Minecraft Fans Microsoft?
Ich verfolge das ja gar nicht.
Also
finden die das gut was die machen?
Oder finden die das eher kacke und sagen vorher war besser?
Ne. Ok.
Die meisten nicht.
Warum nicht?
Weil Microsoft den neuen Client pushen will
und die wollen den Java Client behalten.
Was die Telekom?
Die Telekom stand heute bei mir vor der Tür und wollte mir
neue Glasfaser Ladung anbieten und die maximalen
Geschwindigkeiten waren langsamer und teurer noch dazu.
Ja. Dann.
Da gibts doch dann.
Also dazu gibts ja wirklich
nur noch eins zu sagen.
Piss dich Aldo.
Und Ruhe ist.
Ja.
Und Teams ist auch viel weniger Oracle
als früher.
Wir haben noch ein paar ganz zentrale Dinge auf Oracle.
Aber das meiste
und vieles von dem was früher auf Oracle gelaufen ist
läuft bei uns auch nicht mehr auf Oracle.
Ja. Ist doch klar.
Die haben sie ja auch nicht mehr alle.
Du musst ja
nen Studiengang belegt haben
damit du verstehst
was für Lizenzen du brauchst
und dann erzählen sie dir immer noch.
Ne. Ne. Ne. Sie sind unterlizenziert.
Aber sie können ja unsere Virtualisierungslösung verwenden.
Dann kostet es weniger.
Du hast Microtransactions im neuen
Minecraft.
Warum soll man dann irgendwie
den neuen kleinen spielen?
Wenn man einfach den alten spielen kann ohne Microtransactions.
Das ist irgendwie
komisch.
Hattet ihr früher noch die blauen
Oracle Server? Ne. Wir hatten nie
Server von Oracle.
Wir haben nur Oracle. Aber wir haben
keine Server von Oracle.
Wir hatten damals
einen Opteron Oracle Server
vor ein paar Jahren.
Was? Origin soll bald EA Desktop heißen?
Was? Echt?
Also Origin ist ja schon
bisschen fragwürdig.
Aber das ist
100 pro ne neue Elektron App.
We want you to have best
possible
PC Gaming Experience.
Alles klar. Und dafür brauchen wir
ne neue App. Logisch.
Totaler Schwachsinn.
Totaler Blödsinn.
Also erstens könnte man
das auch alles in Origin machen.
Wenn man das denn
Architekturtechnisch nicht kann.
Das einzige was die machen wollen ist
ein neuer Name. Wahrscheinlich weil
Origin zu langweilig, zu verbraucht
zu was auch immer ist. Das ist ne reine
Marketinggeschichte. Und es ist garantiert
wieder so ne Mischung aus
Moment. Ich hab übrigens Mist erzählt.
Ich hab ja da selbst mal nen Video
zugemacht. Dass Origin
eben nicht Elektron ist.
Ich hab da sogar mal
ein Video zugemacht.
Hier. Und in dem
Video hab ich gezeigt, dass
Ratet mal was Origin ist bevor ihr das Video
guckt. Was meint ihr? Was ist Origin?
Also ich kann euch sagen,
dass ähm
Battlenet so ne
Art Elektron ist.
Und Steam auch so ne Art Elektron.
Allerdings beides nicht wirklich.
Beides ist Chrome Embedded mit ein bisschen anderem
eigenem Geschiss. Das ist, die sind noch aus Zeiten
wo es noch kein Elektron gab.
Ja. Richtig.
Das ist Qt. Ist das.
Ähm. Origin.
Das zeige ich hier auch irgendwo im Video.
Wenn ich das dann mal auf die
Reihe kriege. Genau.
Das verwendet
äh hier Qt Web
Engine.
Und man kann.
Das mache ich irgendwann hier am Ende vom Video auch.
Und man kann wie man hier sieht
sogar die
Ich glaube hier erkennt man es ganz gut.
Man kann die
Developer Tools aufmachen für Origin.
Ja guckt hier. Das sind die
Developer Tools von Origin.
Die kann man aufmachen im Browser.
Dev Tools
Inspector HTML was auch immer.
Ich glaube das geht mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Ja und äh deswegen
weiß ich das ist kein
Elektron. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
das neue Ding wird Elektron.
Weil jeder, jeder macht Elektron
gerade. Allerdings
hier ist es besonders sinnlos.
Weil es muss noch nicht mal eine Cross-Platform App
sein. Der große Vorteil
von Elektron ist ja Cross-Platform
Geschichten.
Ähm.
Und das Frontend Java Skript
Leute auch Desktop Apps machen können.
Aber der große Vorteil von Elektron ist
das der auf jeder Plattform halbwegs läuft.
Wie mich äh das kann äh
das Notizprogramm kann sich so ziemlich über alles
sünken was geht. Ja das kann auch über WebDAV.
Ist Teams nicht auch Elektron?
Doch doch. Das ist fast äh
Slack. Es ist so viel
neues Zeug mittlerweile Elektron.
Bei Teams und Slack und dem ganzen Kram verstehe
ich das. Das soll halt easy
auf Discord übrigens auch
ähm
das soll halt easy auf allen Plattformen
laufen. Und der riesen Vorteil
das muss man jetzt aber auch nochmal
muss man wirklich nochmal sagen.
Neben dieser Cross-Platform Geschichte
also sprich das du äh
eine Seite basteln kannst.
Es ist ja im Prinzip nur eine Webseite mit einem eigenen Fenster
Elektron. Ähm.
Und das die auf Linux,
Windows, Mac äh
ohne Probleme, also ohne Probleme jetzt
zum größten halt ohne Probleme funktioniert
und äh sogar mit ein bisschen Aufriss
auf Handys ohne Probleme funktioniert ist das eine.
Aber warum gerade
Elektron für
solche äh
Communication Apps gut ist. Also
wie gesagt der ganze Kram Flutter ist
top. Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Steht auch noch auf meinem Plan.
Warum gerade Discord ähm
Teams und sowas. Warum die
Elektron verwenden
liegt daran das ist
nicht nur eine Cross-Platform App
das ist eine Cross-Platform Audio Video App.
Spotify ist auch Elektron
ja. Und Audio Video
Zeug Cross-Platform zu machen
ist komplett für
den Arsch. Das willst du nicht selbst machen.
Da musst du dich unter
Windows mit irgendwelchem
DirectX
oder altem GDI Zeug
beschäftigen und und ähm
Direct
Sound oder wie der Geschiss unter
Windows heißt und und ähm
ich habe vergessen wie es heißt.
Das Windows Zeug.
Irgendwelche also du musst dich mit 10 verschiedenen
Sachen unter Windows äh
Windows beschäftigen das du Audio Video
halbwegs machen kannst in Art und Weise
wie das Teams und Discord machen.
Du musst dich unter Linux mit 50
Sachen beschäftigen das du Audio
und Video machen kannst. Wie das
jetzt gerade Discord und Teams machen.
Du musst dich unter Mac mit sagen wir mal auch
10 Sachen beschäftigen. Das ist das
so was Audio Video Zeug
Cross-Platform zu machen ist richtig
Scheiße. So und
da verstehe ich das die Elektron verwenden.
Erstens für die Cross-Platform Geschichte
und gerade weil es Audio Video Zeug ist
weil einfach im Chrome
das schon eingebaut ist. Die müssen das
nicht mehr selbst machen. Und gerade dafür
verstehe ich es wirklich
also wenn ich das
entscheiden müsste ja und mich fragt
einer Max was soll man als was was
verwenden wenn am besten als so
Technologie Grundlage wir wollen
eine App bauen wie Discord. Ohne
Scheiß ihr wisst ich bin kein großartiger
Elektron Fan aber wahrscheinlich würde ich
sagen wir machen das mit Elektron.
Also C und C++
genau.
C++ mit Qt ist
tatsächlich die andere Alternative
wie man bei Origin sieht.
Aber das Problem an Qt ist
also das da meine ich ich meine
ich meine nicht
ich meine nicht das da ich meine das da.
Das ist das andere
einzig richtig
brauchbare Native Cross-Platform
GUI Framework was es gibt.
Alle anderen taugen nix.
Kommt mir bitte keiner mit GTK
oder sowas.
Das
das große Problem an Qt
ist nicht mal Qt selbst.
Qt selbst ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Das Problem ist C++
und C++ ist halt
einfach absolute Zumutung.
Man kann unter Linux
ganz gut die Sache in Python machen
ja aber wenn du
irgendwelche neuen Sachen basteln willst musst du
C++ machen. Die sind ja mittlerweile
auch auf den Trichter
gekommen und haben jetzt
Javascript integriert. Also man kann jetzt
die Sachen auch mit Javascript bis zu einem gewissen
Teil machen. Aber das
wenn du grundlegende Sachen willst musst du das
immer noch mit C++
machen. Und ich bin
ja der meine persönliche Meinung ist
Qt wäre ich meine Qt ist
ziemlich verbreitet. Viele Software
die man so sieht ist tatsächlich hat es in irgendeiner
Form war es mal auf Qt ist Qt
VLC zum Beispiel ja ist auch Qt
vieles vieles
ist darin programmiert. Aber dass das
nie diesen riesen Hype
und diese riesige
Anhängerschaft
und und
Riesenverbreitung
gefunden hat wie es jetzt gerade Elektron ist und
wie Flutter gerade wirklich
sprunghaft nach oben geht ist
erstens und
neunzig Prozent C++
weil C++ einfach sackt
und
das zweite
ist das glaube ich die Mobile
Unterstützung ganz gut ist aber
nicht mithalten kann mit
dem ganzen Javascript und Flutter Zeug
Direct Show hieß das
Direct Show ja kann sein
ich habe mal vor Jahren
als ich angefangen habe mit
YouTube habe ich mal ein bisschen rumgebastelt
mit Direct Show um meine damalige
Blackmagic Capture Card
selbst anzusteuern zum aufnehmen
da wollte ich einen anderen Codec nehmen als den
der eingebaut ist in der Software und das war
richtig eklig komplett für den Arsch
so ähm
genau das ist so die andere Alternative
ansonsten hast du da nicht allzu viel
was Atomfreed
schreibt hey Max bin eher so
der stille Zuschauer wollte dir mal sagen
dass ich dich schon seit Ewigkeiten auf YouTube verfolge
und du auch der Grund dafür bist dass ich wirklich
Interesse am Programmieren und an Technik
bekommen habe ja das ist
ich habe jetzt glaube ich habe das Emoji
aber das ist wirklich
sehr white people happy
habe ich das gar nicht drin
warum habe ich das nicht doch hier
das habe ich gesagt exzellent
ähm
ja das ist schön dass das
bei dir
gefruchtet hat
ich habe viele hier im
Stream die schon gesagt haben sie haben auch eine Ausbildung
angefangen wegen den Videos und sowas gemacht haben
das finde ich immer richtig nice
und nicht zu vergessen
heute ich weiß nicht ob du ganz am Anfang vom Stream schon da warst
heute hat mir mein Azubi erzählt
oder gestern oder so irgendwann in den letzten Tage
ähm
dass er auch meine Videos früher geguckt hat
ja aber es ist nice dass das
bei dir so gelaufen ist
Chat
der Chat vielleicht
ja ich vermute es hiermit sind auch Elektronen
ja das
ist korrekt das stimmt
auch Projekt den C++ aufzusetzen
ist einfach eklig weil es kein
es gibt es gibt
ähm das da
das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht
das dumme ist nur dass es nur unter
Windows richtig gut funktioniert
so
ähm es ich will jetzt nicht
davon anfangen weil wie gesagt
dann werde ich die letzten
fuck ich bin beim Stuhl
ich versuche gerade mit meinem Stuhl runter zu springen
von meinem Headset Kabel
so wunderbar
ähm
hehehe
Mokka Smokka
es klüht schon
das ist ganz okay das Ding
aber ähm
das fehlt an so vielen Ecken und Enden
das ist einfach eine komplette
Zumutung ja
und das ist glaube ich auch der Grund warum Qt sich nicht so
wahnsinnig gehypt ist und so wahnsinnig durchgesetzt hat
und das hier wird garantiert
wird garantiert ähm
es gibt viele
es gibt ja ja es gibt viele ähm
es gibt nicht nur es gibt auch noch
äh Bazaar ne äh
ach keine Ahnung wie das heißt
es gibt ein paar das ist aber auch so ein bisschen
das Problem
sowas wie ein Paketmanager
das muss vom Hersteller kommen
ja also das das hast du
bei allem gesehen ja Rust hat Cargo
ähm
das ganze Dotnet Zeug hat Nougat
dann Ruby hat Gem
Python hat Pip und und äh
was wird
der Vorgänger von Pip ist es jetzt
äh
äh Node hat NPM
und
ja was auch immer
aber äh
wenn sowas nicht vom Hersteller kommt
dann wird das nix
ja sowas das Problem
was die bei C++ ja auch haben ist
dass die gar kein gar kein richtiges
Paketformat so so haben oder auch
auch kein oder zumindest jetzt noch
nicht kein richtiges Modul
Exportverfahren die haben ja immer noch
diesen diesen äh
Header Scheiß
der mehr Probleme macht als
das er irgendwie was bringt
ich mein im Jahr 2020
mit Header Files zu hantieren
ist äh ein
ein extrem Huge Pain Champ
Punkt
redet der vom Spiel Rust
ne ne also
ganz ehrlich also ihr wisst das C++
und ich keine keine Freunde mehr werden
ja gibt es dazu schon Bilder
von diesem komischen
EA Desktop Ding?
EA Desktop?
gibt es da Bilder?
Origin heißt jetzt EA Desktop
ja super ganz doll
Moment
einen größeren Screenshot hätte es nicht getan oder?
äh WPF per RDP
oh ganz ehrlich habe ich ewig nicht probiert
ähm aber übrigens äh hier
das ist ein guter Punkt
da kann ich mich jetzt mal kurz zu auslassen
das ist ja auch was was mir immer sehr am Herzen liegt
warte mal ob ich den Chat dass ich das zeigen kann
äh wo hat hier einer was von WPF geschrieben
ich finde es mühsam
dass viele Developer WPF einsetzen
das zeugt noch viel
dir bleibt ja unter Windows gar nichts anderes da übrig
außer Windows Forms oder WPF zu verwenden
dir bleibt ja als normaler
Entwickler nichts anderes übrig
Microsoft hat es ja nicht geschafft die letzten 15 Jahre
nen GUI Framework rauszubringen
außer man nimmt sowas wie
Electron und Qt
was meint ihr warum sogar Windows Only Anti-Viren Scanner Oberflächen
mittlerweile in Electron sind
weil es nichts gescheites gibt von Microsoft
ähm die haben es ja die letzten 15 Jahre
nicht geschafft
ein ordentliches konkurrenzfähiges modernes UI Framework
äh rauszubringen
was die aktuellen Windows Sachen unterstützt
die haben dann irgendwann mal angefangen
vor frag mich nicht 8 Jahren oder 10 Jahren
mit UWP
UWP war von Anfang an einfach Schrott
mittlerweile ist es
ein Ticken weniger Schrott aber immer noch Schrott
ich kann es auch gerne erklären
warum ich meine
also wenn es keiner wissen will lasse ich jetzt mal dabei
warum ich UWP für Schrott halte
ähm
jetzt erst
2020 gibt es eine Beta Version
von ähm
von dem hier
und das wird das erste UI Framework
das ist quasi UWP
nur so verpackt
ähm
das es ohne UWP läuft
also die haben die guten GUI
Teile von UWP genommen
und
haben was neues draus gemacht
es ist der Witz
dass das immer noch nicht am Start ist
totaler Witz
ähm wieso hältst du UWP für Schrott
also für mich
als jemand der Windows Anwendung
jetzt nicht
für seinen Lebensunterhalt programmiert
ist ein ganz großer Painschampunkt
an UWP ist
du hast nur 2 Varianten
du kannst es über den Store vertreiben
oder du kannst es Sideloaden
aber du kannst es nicht Sideloaden
also Microsoft
sagt du kannst es über den Store vertreiben
oder du kannst es Sideloaden
nur mit dem Unterschied
dass du es realistisch betrachtet
nicht Sideloaden kannst
ähm das Problem dabei ist
du brauchst ein gültiges Codesigning Zertifikat
das der User nicht entweder
Adminrechte benötigt
um dein Zertifikat hinzuzufügen
oder der User überhaupt sich erstmal traut
das zu machen
also du kannst
du kannst nicht einfach eine Anwendung
äh programmieren die nützlich ist
und sagen hier
Windows typisch du kannst das hier installieren
du brauchst ein gültiges
Codesigning Zertifikat
du kannst das mal 200 Euro im Jahr ausgeben
dass du ähm blessed bist
von Microsoft
äh eventuell deine Windows Anwendung machen zu können
so das ist auch
auch der Grund warum viele Leute immer noch
UWP ähm WPF und Windows Forms
und sowas verwenden
also das ist ein ganz großer äh
Painschamp was UWP Anwendung
angeht
man braucht ein gültiges Codesigning Zertifikat
so der nächste Schrott den
UWP angeht
warum UWP kacke ist
der jetzt besser wird mit WinUI 3 mit der Geschichte hier
ist das es immer noch
so viele Restriktionen hat
man konnte bis glaube ich die vorletzte Version
und und ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob es jetzt geht aber ich glaube ich hab was gelesen
du konntest mit UWP bis die vorletzte
UWP Version konntest du keine Screenshots
machen
und was bis heute nicht geht
die wollen halt das es besonders abgeschottet ist
aber das mal ganz ehrlich
die meisten Windows Anwendungen
sind halt nicht gescheit abgeschottet
funktionieren Sachen die so im App
im App Store Apple Style sind
ja so irgendein Kalender der vielleicht
irgendwas braucht aber zum Beispiel
ein Tool was
ähm andere OBS
OBS könnte man
niemals als UWP umsetzen
es geht nicht das ist nicht
möglich OBS
als ähm
UWP umzusetzen das geht nicht
äh man man
konnte so eine komische Bridge
programmieren die dann
als alter
total wir und da konntest du wieder nicht ins Store
also
es ist fürn Arsch
kurz gesagt so
ähm viel zu viel
Restriktion und viel zu viel Gängelung
vom Anwender
was der eigentlich machen müsste damit er seine Anwendung
benutzen kann also komplett fürn Arsch
letztendlich ja
deswegen ist UWP Schrott
und die sind leider sehr spät dran
die sind jetzt dabei
sowas hier zu programmieren
WinUI 3 ist übrigens das aktuelle
und wir haben es auch schon mal im Stream
ausprobiert leider haben sie es noch nicht geschafft
das ähm Native
Windows Anwendung also
sagen wir mal so es gibt UWP
Anwendungen Packaged UWP Anwendungen
und es gibt Unpackaged Anwendungen
also alles was UWP ist
ist Packaged Anwendung alles was nicht UWP ist
ist Unpackaged Anwendung
die zwei Sachen zu unterscheiden
für Packaged Anwendungen brauchst du
zwingend ein Code Signing Zertifikat
ansonsten
kriegt dein User
ach ja ach ja
was auch Schrott ist
du brauchst ein Code Signing Zertifikat
oder du musst es über den Store vertreiben
dann signed Microsoft es für dich
es geht nicht Cheat 95
die Packaged App
die muss
signed sein ansonsten wenn die nicht
signiert ist mit einem gültigen Code Signing
Zertifikat was ein paar hundert Euro im Jahr
kostet muss der User
im Installer
in deinem Zertifikat
trusten
damit er deinem Zertifikat trusten kann
braucht er zwingend Admin Rechte auf dem System
das ist
das macht viele Anwendungen schon mal
komplett Unusable
stellt euch mal vor Notepad++
zum Beispiel ist ja immer noch
warum auch immer ist ja immer noch beliebt unter Windows
Notepad++
als UWP Anwendung
es könnte niemand sich installieren
auf seinem Arbeitsrechner
weil er keine Admin Rechte hat
also
jetzt erst an
mit diesen Geschichten hier
UWP für Unpackaged Apps
also nein die UWP GUI Komponente
für Unpackaged Apps
bereitzustellen
Preview 2 ist noch Schrott
wir haben Preview 1 ausprobiert
da gingen Unpackaged Apps noch gar nicht
also auch Schrott
und mit Preview 3
sollen angeblich Unpackaged Apps kommen
was ist das denn
ist das denn
ich hab mir das PS Event geschaut
eigentlich muss ich ins Bett
ich muss morgen wieder früh aufstehen und arbeiten gehen
ich kann mir das PS5 Event nicht anschauen
wie gesagt
ich bin jetzt schon 9 Tage am Stück am arbeiten
das suckt gerade ein bisschen
also ihr könnt dann ruhig um 10 alle abhauen
und das PS5 Event gucken
da bin ich euch nicht böse
was ist das denn
hehehe
oh
das gucken wir uns am Sonntag an
9 Tage am Stück jaja
ich rede wirklich von 9 Tagen am Stück
und ich rede nicht von am Wochenende
wirklich 9 Tage am Stück
ohne Unterbrechung
aber so viel dazu
Microsoft hat es einfach verschissen
die letzten 15 Jahren
ordentliches UI Framework rauszubringen
ist bei euch der Server durchgegeben
ja nicht nur einer
was genau ist denn los
das kann ich nicht erzählen
an deiner Tableiste kann ich erkennen
dass du mindestens 128
das sind
komm
das sind vielleicht 15 Tabs
das ist doch nicht viel
gerade wenn wir irgendwelche Sachen programmieren
hier habe ich teilweise keine Ahnung
55 Tabs auf oder so
also wenn es dich interessiert
ich habe 32G
ja 32G habe ich
und ohne VMs ist die Auslastung
eigentlich viel zu hoch
aber
nicht hoch
die USB Sticks habe ich doch danach mitgebracht
das wäre aber durchaus möglich
die waren so schlecht
die fangen bestimmt Feuer demnächst
genau
ja und wie gesagt
hier hat Microsoft einfach massiv verschissen
ich hoffe das die das gebacken kriegen
mit der nächsten Version
das kenne ich nicht
das gucken wir uns aber am Sonntag an
jaja wie gesagt
ziemlich viel ist abgeraucht
nice
ja das einzige Problem an Joplin ist an dieser App
dass die halt Elektron ist
das ist das einzige
also am liebsten würde ich eigentlich
ja aber
es ist finde ich für mich
die beste Note on to do App
deswegen sehe ich da mal über
Elektron hinweg
ansonsten bin ich ja ziemlich
anti Elektron
äh
guck mal ich finde es interessant
die Leute passen ja auf hier im Stream
also exzellent
Big Brain Chat wieder
ich hab gedacht du darfst keine Serverarbeiten mehr machen
ja gut am Server selbst mache ich ja auch nix
aber dafür sorgen dass das
Zeug wieder geht darf ich trotzdem noch
wenn Not am Mann ist
wie synchronisiert sich dein
Job
so heißt das
ähm
klar kannst du das self-hosted über die Cloud machen
du kannst das über so ziemlich
alles machen
du gibst dem ein Verzeichnis an was gesynkt ist und das synkt
und du kannst ihm auch direkt Nextcloud angeben
und sonst was
schon mal mit Teal Storage unter Windows
nein hab ich noch nicht
ja das stimmt da hast du recht
ich hab kein englisches Tastatur Layout
das gebetet dich die Anzeige da unten
die Anzeige gebetet dich
ich hab äh englische Sprache
und deutsches Tastatur Layout
hehehe Freedom
Freedom Language
der einzige Grund
warum ich das auf Englisch stehen hab
zwei Gründe
die deutsche Übersetzung ist meistens Müll
und daraus resultiert
dass wenn du
nach Fehlermeldungen suchst
du auf deutsch keine Antworten findest
suchst du nach Fehlermeldungen auf Englisch
findest du alles sofort
erster Stack Overflow Eintrag ist das Ergebnis
oder erster Stack Exchange ist das Ergebnis
ja das hab ich nicht probiert
also
ich seh keinen Sinn drinnen
aktuell mir ein neues Tastatur Layout
anzueignen irgendwo
ähm erstens kriegst du Anfälle
wenn du mal auf eine andere Tastatur tippen musst
und ähm
zweitens halte ich
den Lernaufwand für nicht gerechtfertigt
aber ist ja gut wenn es für dich klappt
also hat ja jeder so sein Zeug
sogar UK Englisch
tatsächlich
das englische Tastatur Layout
ist nicht verkehrt
das hat die Klammern beispielsweise viel besser gelegen
als bei uns
an sich ist das
man merkt dass das englische Tastatur Layout
also
so eines der ursprünglichen PC Layout
schlechthin ist
aber ich hab mich jetzt so an das deutsche Tastatur Layout gewähnt
ja
finde ich gut
weil es die einzige Möglichkeit ist unter macOS ordentlich Sachen zu installieren
ja sehe ich
aber ich sehe nicht wer
ich sehe was die Leute kaufen
aber nicht wer
wer wäre ja auch irgendwie datenschutzmäßig bedenklich
mach dir nichts draus
es bestellen Leute dort so viel merkwürdige Sachen
da fällt mir das nicht auf
wenn du was merkwürdiges bestellst
außerdem weiß ich ja gar nicht dass du das bist
ja gut Cortana ist
ich hab alle Voice Assistants abgeschaltet
ich hab keine Voice Assistants bei mir
ich hab sogar Siri ausgeschaltet
das einzige wo ich es für legitim halte
Siri zu verwenden
was bei mir halt so gut wie nicht vorkommt
ist wenn man Auto fährt
also wenn man im Auto unterwegs ist
dann ist Voice Control sinnvoll
ne Classic Shell ist auch doof
hab ich auch mal ausprobiert
ist auch hakelig irgendwie
und ändert ja nicht großartig was
also am Rest ist es auch doof
PS5 Showcase
PS5 Showcase gleich
ich weiß ich weiß
deswegen geh ich jetzt oft dass ihr PS5 Showcase gucken könnt
weil ich kann leider
ich würd streamen aber es ist leider zu spät
für mich muss morgen arbeiten gehen
hier die Tastatur hätte ich dazu beim streamen
Ducky One Skyline
also nur
weil ich hier aus eigener Erfahrung sprechen kann
dass sie ziemlich gut ist
allerdings die mit Numplog wohlgemerkt
ja also hier
mit numplog
wo auch immer mit numplog
ähm ich weiß nicht ob die besser
oder schlechter ist als andere von denen
ich weiß nur ich find sie super
ich hab die jetzt seit ner ganzen Weile
auf der Arbeit im Einsatz
wunderbar kann man sehr gut mitarbeiten
hast du deine Nvidia Socken noch
das sind keine Nvidia Socken das waren Nvidia Schuhe
Nvidia Sneaker Schuhe
waren das die hab ich noch ja
wie kann man sich ne Tastatur ohne
numplog kaufen ja frag ich mich auch
die Musik ist so leise ja gerade ist es
ziemlich leise aber ich mach jetzt auch nicht lauter
weil ich jetzt äh
aufgeh
wer braucht den numplog numplog ist beste
ohne
guck mal also im numplog lässt sich viel einfacher hier
irgendwelche Zahlen tippen als da oben über diese
komische komische Leiste ja
ne
ist aber wie bei vielen Geschmackssache
mal gucken wann ich
das nächste mal ankommen kann Leute es kann sein
dass ich am Sonntag keinen Aufwachstream machen kann
wie gesagt weil arbeit technisch ist gerade voll
am Arsch ist ne wie gesagt
ist jetzt der neunte Tag in Folge
ohne Wochenende wohlgemerkt Wochenende hab ich auch
geschafft neun Tage in Folge weil bei uns
so viel Zeug kaputt gegangen ist
mal gucken
mal gucken wie das die nächsten Tage läuft
wir müssen ja noch unseren Webserver basteln
auf dem ESP32
aber ich hoffe das ich Sonntag
frei hab und Aufwachstream machen kann
so Leute guckt mal PS5 Event
geht jetzt gleich los also wenns interessiert
und
wir sehen uns dann denke
hoffe ich mal die Tage
war heute eher spontane Geschichte wir haben ja nichts wirklich sinnvolles
zustande gebracht
also machts gut Chat
bis denn
wir sehen uns CU
brauchen wir Outromusik
wir brauchen Outromusik
brauchen wir unbedingt
Outromusik
alles klar machts gut
bis denn